let's add for 11 to 9 over 13 so we need
in order to add these two fractions we
need to find a common denominator and
that common denominator needs to be the
least common multiple of 11 and 13 and
these two numbers they don't share any
common factors so their least common
multiple this is really just going to be
the product of 11 and 13 so we could say
13 times 13 times 11 13 times 1 is 13 13
times another one is 13 or you could say
13 times 10 is 130 and we get 3 4 1 143
so that's going to be our common
denominator so I'll write it over here
so something over 143 plus something
else over 143 and to go from 4 11 to
something over 143 we multiplied the 11
times 13 so or we multiply the
denominator times 13 so we're gonna have
to multiply the numerator times 13 as
well and 4 times 13 let's see 4 times 10
is 40 4 times 3 is 12 so it gives us 52
and you can work that out by hand if you
like 4 times 13 is 52 and then to go
from 13 to 143 we multiplied by 11 so if
we multiply the denominator by 11 if we
don't want to change the value of the
fraction we have to multiply the
numerator by 11 9 times 11 is 99 and now
we're ready to add this is equal to our
common denominator is 143 and 52 plus 99
52 plus 100 would be 152 and this is
going to be one less than that so it's
going to be 151 and I think that's about
as simplified as we can get as far as I
know it doesn't look like they're any
common factors between 151 and 143 so we
just get 151 over 143 we can write this
as a mixed number because 143 goes into
151 one time 1 times 143 is 143 when you
subtract let's see this can become an 11
this is a 4 11 minus 3 is 8 you have a
remainder of 8 so this is the same thing
once
51 over 143 is the same thing as 1 1 & 8
8 140 thirds and now it becomes even
more clear that these can't be
simplified any more so and we are done
this is the same thing as 1 all right
the one a little bit bigger one and 8
140 thirds